all right so III zapatos there's like a
thousand things I should talk about
there's not enough time to get to
everything I blogged about a couple
things but this I'm going to talk about
and that is Nintendo's new system the
Wii U a system that's getting 2
responses people are either gone are you
serious it sucks or the like and I
personally love it I'm going to talk
about why I'm Nintendo is no stranger
for innovation intend ods innovative 3ds
innovative jet launch titles but you
know and the Wii with its motion
controllers let everyone know that it's
ok to game like that and the next thing
you know to other companies come out
with their answer to the Wii motion
controller safe to say we was innovative
however by appealing to the casual gamer
in the family aspect they alienated a
lot of the hardcore gamers out there our
core gamers really play xbox 360 or ps3
so what the Wii U promises to do is
bridge that gap it promises to appeal
the casual gamers as well as hardcore
gamers and by that they really have to
graphically step it up I hate to sound
like a graphic snob or anything like
that but the Wii is behind the Xbox 360
and ps3 but the Wii U is displayed at
1080p and they didn't have any full
games to demonstrate I really don't know
what to say in terms of graphics about
the thing they just had a lot of tech
demos to show but they did have some
gameplay footage of a couple games some
look good some looked alright Tekken
looks a little bit ps2 to me but Ninja
Gaiden a couple others looked really
good but a really interesting aspect of
the Wii U is the controller because it
doesn't look like a controller when you
first see the thing you're like that is
going to be uncomfortable as hell to
play for like three hours I mean it
looks like is that big and has a screen
in the middle for things like an iPad
meets a controller when you look on the
back you see these little ridges where
you can rest your hands with L&R buttons
you're like okay it looks a little more
comfortable and people who tried it out
at e3 they say the controller's actually
really light so it has all the
conventional buttons the L and R buttons
the d-pad everything that makes the
controller controller then it has this
screen in the middle that you can also
use it's a touch pad it's another screen
for games it's a solo screen for games
they show people playing like casual
games that you play on like iPads
Android phones and it shows how you can
use that screen on the controller in the
game like in baseball games you can aim
where you want a pitch you can use it as
like a sniper scope and sniper games I'm
one of the coolest things about the
screen I think is you can turn your TV
off and you can still play the game on
the screen on the Wii U controller
that's badass and everything from the
Wiis backwards-compatible on this to all
your wii games play on the Wii U all the
accessories the Wiimote the nunchuck
they all play on the Wii U I don't know
if my downloaded games and channels they
transfer over also though because if
they do you can just toss the Wii or
trade it in or something but one of the
coolest announcements
came with the WiiU is the fact that
they're making a Super Smash Brothers
for the Wii U and a 3ds and supposedly
they're gonna work together somehow
that's awesome and the big Smash
Brothers fan Chris deck mine's going
down so I personally think the Wii U
looks really cool this could very well
bridge the gap between casual gamer and
hardcore gamer I hope not every
developer goes overboard I like seeing
those eccentric really innovative games
if I just have a normal game with normal
controls and high def with sweet
graphics that can keep up with the Xbox
360 and ps3 it just uses that little
screen on the controller for the sake of
me wanting to play the game while they
watch TV I am good put a video below
that shows you a little bit about it go
check it out come back here comment
below let me know what you think about
this and if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
are you serious it sucks but why is it
sorry because it sucks well why does it
sorry cuz it sucks so why is it sad cuz
its Wii U sucks let's go drink